tu
le
si vous avez 50 ans et plus serge fiori
faire partie de votre bagage musical de
la fraîcheur des premiers albums à la
gravité du magnifique album double le
stade
serge fiori et harmonium ont marqué une
époque après des années difficiles une
anxiété qui a freiné l'artiste qui n'a
jamais arrêté de faire de la musique
fiori sort donc un nouvel album et
accorder une entrevue télévisée à
monique giroux d' espace musique de
radio-canada d'air je vous dis que
l'entrevue sera diffusé à ici radio
canada télé dimanche à 23h l'entrevue
intégrale que nous résume maxence
bilodeau cela ça va donner un gros coup
pour - le boxeur obtient pas qu'un
boycott sont bonnes un gros coup serge
fiori à 62 ans quand on est une icône et
qu'on a fabriqué d'albums depuis 28 ans
normal d'avoir quelques appréhensions
je pense le monde m'attend là qu'une
brique mes enfants là ce genre
comme si je me rêve comme
serge fiori c'est en chanson le québec
des années soixante dix on le voit ici
avec harmonium à l'un des spectacles
mythiques du groupe
la fête nationale sur le mont royal en
1976 la musique oui mais en plus sa voix
quel poids exceptionnel unique comme
douter
le groupe a une vie relativement courte
de 74 à 78 ensuite fiori éprouvent des
difficultés personnelles la scène le
paralyse
et il disparaît le revoici donc près de
quarante ans plus tard avec un nouvel
album de 10 chansons originales
toi aussi
j'm'en
je
les paroles sont parfois un peu simple
mais fille aurait réussit
particulièrement bien dans les thèmes
intérieurs ses douleurs ses angoisses
ses parents quand un choix pourtant
ports font mal de gens pensent que je
suis pas au mieux un mot enfin je parle
de mes parents il n'a pas donné de
spectacle depuis 36 ans serait-il
maintenant capable de remonter sur scène
se sont se confond mais fiori craint de
se retrouver rattrapé par ses démons à
nouveau paralysé en plein milieu du
spectacle par une crise d'anxiété
problème un neurotransmetteur
physiologique faisait 5 tonnes en dés et
aux densités tampon norman une chose à
la fois d'abord l'album je veux
tellement ça marche un jeu tellement que
ça soit vraiment s'invente justement
l'ajax et ils sont nombreux à le lui
souhaiter
serge vous êtes vraiment merci merci
merci pour
sens ici maxence bilodeau radio-canada
bon maire
e